avec nous maintenant steven guilbeault
le ministre de l'environnement et du
changement climatique on retrouve ce
soir avec la sgo bonsoir monsieur
guilbeault
bonsoir monsieur clients d'abord dans
quel état vous trouvez-vous présentement
dans quel état d'esprit je devrais vous
dire alors qu'on sent qu'on achève
quelque chose est ce qu'on va réussir
est ce que ce sera une réussite ou un
échec
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce soir
le climat est prudemment optimiste je
dirais une plénière aujourd'hui à
laquelle j'ai participé et on sent qu'il
ya encore certains éléments qui est qui
qui achoppe au niveau des négociations
mais on sent aussi un certain optimisme
et on qu'on s'approche d'un accord qui
va nous permettre d'aller encore plus
loin dans la lutte aux changements
climatiques à l'échelle planétaire sur
les questions de l'adaptation ce qu'on
appelle la finance climatique également
je pense qu on est prêts on est prêt de
quelque chose les britanniques ont fait
un travail
absolument fantastique au cours des
dernières semaines et je dirais depuis
un an et demi qu'il travaille à préparer
cette conférence là et il faut saluer
tous travaillent les nations unies
disent le monde se dirige vers un
réchauffement de 2 à 7 degrés l'objectif
là c'est d'aller de limiter à 1,5 degré
est ce que vous sentez qu'est la
conclusion prochaine la de cette coop 26
on adopte les actions nécessaires pour
arriver véritablement à limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degré
c'est une excellente question et si on
se rapporte dans le temps avant la
conférence de paris avant paris on se
dirigeait vers un réchauffement trois
points 7 degrés celsius et avant comme
vous l'avez précisé avant la conférence
de glace cause que les experts nous
disséquons se diriger et on dirige vers
un réchauffement de 2 points 7 degrés
celsius alors que l'accord de paris dit
qu'il faut que ce soit tout au plus deux
préférablement vers 1.5 et la semaine
dernière l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie nous a dit mais en fonction
des engagements qui ont été pris ici à
glasgow on se dirigerait vers un monde
où la température augmenterait de 1.8
degrés celsius soit évidemment c'est
cesser dans la perspective où tout le
monde met en place les mesures que qu'il
sent guère kébé elle s'engage à déployer
au cours des prochaines années mais
touche on nous montre que le travail
fonctionne mais évidemment il faut le
faire il faut continuer de le faire il
faut le faire parce que si une chose
qu'on doit retenir c'est qu'il faut
accélérer la lutte aux changements
climatiques
est-ce que d'éliminer les subventions
aux énergies fossiles
c'est assez est-ce que c'est assurément
réduire la production de pétrole
est-ce que c'est assez non et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi au canada on inscrit
sur la pollution c'est pourquoi en plus
de travailler sur des mesures comme
réduire la pollution du méthane qui
produit par le secteur du pétrole et de
gaz qui est un gaz à effet de serre très
puissants nous travaillons aussi sur la
demande alors des robes des
investissements records en transport
collectif il ya 300 projets de
transports collectifs en construction
présente mon pays plus de mille ans
processus d'approbation
l'électrification des transports les
transports actifs l'efficacité
énergétique donc tout ça va faire en
sorte qu'on va réduire notre demande
de produits pétroliers de produits
gaziers mais l'élimination des
subventions c'est certainement de choses
important mais en plus de ça nous sommes
engagés à mettre un plafond sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
pétrole et du gaz qu'on fait pas pour le
secteur de l'acier ou l'aluminium ou
encore
l'automobile pourquoi le pétrole et le
gaz mais parce que c'est 25% des
émissions
nous estimons qu'il faut en faire encore
plus mais là au moment où on se parle
l'association des services pétroliers du
canada nous dit que les puits forés en
2022 vont revenir aux niveaux de 2010 9
qu'on revient comme avant est ce qu'on
on a l'impression que malgré tout ce
qu'on se dit on va fort et plus puis on
va produire plus de pétrole au canada
dans les faits
moi je prendrai avec un grain de sel
cesser ses prévisions la de
l'association je pense que on va voir
que plus nous allons avancer plus par
exemple la tarification carbone va
augmenter la tarification carbone
canadienne est déjà l'une des plus
ambitieuses après 2022 le prix sur la
tonne de notre plat de 10 $ à nîmes est
de 15 $ par année ce qu'il faut nous en
2030 le des deux ou trois pays au monde
où la tarification carbone soit la plus
ambitieuse alors l'ensemble de ces
mesures là à la fois donc celle que j'ai
parlé kiki qui vise précisément le
secteur du pétrole et du gaz mais
également tous tout ce qui est en train
de se passer du côté de la réduction de
la demande de produits de pétroliers de
combustibles fossiles inévitablement de
l'un dans l'autre va faire en sorte que
nous allons progressivement il est de
plus en plus progressivement réduire
notre dépendance aux hydrocarbures
le budget fédéral d'avril dernier fin de
classe importante au captage et le
stockage du carbone c'est quoi pour vous
monsieur guilbeault l'importance de
cette technologie là dans le plan de
réduction du canada
vous êtes une place importante je
relativiserait quand même là on
n'investit pas je vous dirai dans le
budget avec toute une description
incitatives fiscales et on présente
ailleurs le cryptage comme étant une
technologie qui fonctionne dans le
budget fédéral
en termes d'investissements on est à 30
milliards d'investissements au cours des
dix prochaines années dans les
transports collectifs on est à plus de
10 milliards dans la dans des
technologies déjà existantes pour le
secteur de l'acier par exemple ou
l'aluminium
l aluminium verre donc il serait sans
émissions de gaz à effet de serre est ce
que est ce que c'est le giec a fait un
rapport sur le captage et le stockage du
carbone en disant que c'est que ce
serait une solution qu'on devrait qu'on
devrait utiliser mais faut bien
comprendre que c'est pas pour demain
matin la veille
c'est pas là dessus qu'on mise pour
réduire nos émissions au cours des
prochaines années mais est ce que c'est
une garantie de votre coffre à outils le
communiste de l'environnement oui
oui parce que il y à l'échelle
planétaire ce sera l'une des mesures qui
va être utilisé mais à court terme on
est dans l'efficacité énergétique on est
dans les renouvelables on est dans le
transport collectif on est dans
l'efficacité énergétique
parce que ces technologies elles sont là
elles sont prouvées elle existe il ya
beaucoup de nouvelles technologies dont
nous allons avoir de besoins en cours de
techno au cours des prochaines années
comme le captage et le stockage du
carbone mais on est à plusieurs années
d'une utilisation commerciale voire même
une décennie bien on suit de toute façon
les prochaines heures la coop 26 merci
monsieur guilbeault d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci beaucoup monsieur
clients merci au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit